philipp hat leppmeier ist alles was
nicht nur steiner sagt gar keinen
unterschied machen ein spiel rat wäre
ich bin es geht um schriftstellerinnen
und schriftsteller die der andere
erraten muss also rate mal wer ich bin
von dieser person habe ich wirklich viel
gelesen ist schon der erste hinweis für
mich ja okay ist eine frau und sie hat
sich auch sehr engagiert für tiere
kinder menschenrechte oder haben sie
noch am leben ein 2002 gestorben in
recht hohem alter hast du denn können ja
ich bin so super ja zeigt mir zeigt mir
den preis warum hast du das jetzt
bewusst wie du erhältst du mich
eigentlich ja entschuldige astrid
lindgren hast du mir nicht mal erzählt
dass du kannst eigentlich nicht leiden
gehabt was da noch hasse ich doch magst
du die nicht gruselig finde so ein
kleiner entschuldige dicker junge der
total nervt wenn ich habe ihn geliebt
warum also selbst weil ich immer noch
dick pummelig und hinterhältig bis zum
heutigen tag bin meine damen und herren
deswegen kann ich mich so stark wie du
bist so eine größer war ja das sage ich
heute noch wenn leute so hart du liebe
zeit gegeben haben dass uns auf den
kanton oder die astrid lindgren das
leben prägt das ist so zeit und wie sie
so typen erschafft die man einfach
durchs ganze leben lang groß an der hand
hat in erster linie welche astrid
lindgren ausgewählt weil ich wissen
wollte ob du auch so ein astrid lindgren
feldes die ich also es gibt ganz wenige
bücher von ihr die mich einfach nie
interessiert wie zum beispiel löwenherz
aber die anderen lieb ich großartig auf
jahren aus der krachmacherstraße und so
also wahnsinnig 70 auch weiß dass
interessante finde ich das ganz viele
bücher von ihr auf eine einfache art und
weise philosophische themen verhandeln
nämlich was ist das miteinander wie sind
die regeln was ist wichtig was ist
zivilisiert und was ist frei und wird
auch so anarchisch irgendwie so will die
lange ja ich dachte mir vielleicht ist
es raus geschnitten worden
deswegen habe ich sag mal wiederholt
jetzt verkauft er das was ich sage als
seien es macht darüber so schalten sie
nächste woche wieder ein
in der schule
[Musik]